would you say starting a film career at
age 35 is too late NOP I don't think so
I mean I think you can start it when
you're like 45 um but hopefully uh
you've thought it through uh hopefully
um you
know you have to have it depends what
you want to do right like if if you're a
producer well I mean look if you have a
good sense of story and you like to read
a lot uh that's you know one type of
producer in terms of being creative but
do you are you a people person do you
like talking to people do you like
solving problems I mean that's another
kind of producer um if you want to
direct I mean look I get that's in a lot
of people's hearts but I feel like there
there are a few people that deserve to
direct that have really thought it
through I mean like the technical aspect
of like the camera of where their they
they can have the idea and the passion
on the page let's say but some haven't
really thought about how how this is
going to move or that's going to move
and they don't have the wherewithal to
hire somebody who's a great DP to help
Shepherd them through the process let's
say right um I think it's much hard I I
I fear ever if someone I have nightmares
where I have to direct something that's
my nightmare because I just think
there's so there's so much goes on in
that whole thing like that I I just know
my brain doesn't work that way I but
it's my nightmare like I was if I was
ever half to gun to the gun to head if I
did direct something I'd be like I'm
just going to have a panic attack I've
never had a panic attack in my life but
I like literally having a dream about
this right now like we're having a
nightmare like you know I think that
there is a certain amount of learning
and skill that goes into certain
positions like if you want to be um you
know the art director or the production
designer or somebody like that I think
you have to put in the time I think you
probably have to put in like what is it
10 years before you get good at
something as they say right I think that
those are there certain positions where
it may be harder to start later in life
but there are other things that um you
know you could already be very well
versed for um you know if you love
reading and you love stories and you
love you know even editing you could
probably start later in life but you
need to you know probably take a lot of
classes and also be a be a a junior what
is it assistant assistant editor for
many years before you get to the place
where you're going to like be able to be
trusted to do that in any big capacity
would you hire a 60-year-old first-time
director
I think that's a tough question actually
I mean it depends
on I don't know it to me it depends
um it depends on the are they WR are
they the writer director or because if
they're the writer director then maybe
there's something to that because you
know look that's that's truly their
Vision on the page from to to whatever
it is so I mean I feel I feel about
better about hiring writer directors in
general than I do about hiring a
director versus and a writer
it's like the same person has to be
satisfied which is good just one person
right um but going back to question
6-year-old director depend on the person
depend on the project uh that's what I
would
say what about a person 65 or older
writing a screenplay for the first time
I mean look there's tons of like online
classes there's tons of things to learn
how to get the format right in terms of
like helping with structure helping you
with maybe actual some of the subject
matter
um there's a lot of really great
firsttime screenwriters right
um I would have no problem with that
depending on how good the script is you
know you there's a lot of experienc
screenwriters write a lot of shitty
things too by the way so it's like
there's
no I would have no problem with it
depending on the person of course cliche
question but I just have to ask it best
piece of advice someone gave you
starting out and worst piece of advice
you leave out the names to protect the
non-innocent
um well going back to the shorts you're
making a short make it short that's that
was one good piece of advice
um what's what was the worst
advice Rotten Tomatoes doesn't
matter I had a publicist tell me this
one time Rotten Tomatoes doesn't matter
and I I got in a yelling match with with
them and I was like are you out of your
mind let me tell you why it matters
because when you're dealing with a movie
maybe for horror movies it doesn't
matter cuz it doesn't sometimes it
really doesn't like you know whatever
slasher it doesn't matter when you have
a movie that rides the line between
genres that could be a thriller and it
could be uh you know a horror movie
right it absolutely does matter because
what's happening in this day and age
what that that this person didn't
realize is that
the different streamers are putting that
number that Rotten Tomato certified
fresh right next to your movie when
people are scrolling through that movie
that pops up literally in the scrolling
it'll pop up and I can say oh wait
that's 88% I might give that a chance
okay why not let's try it the other
thing they do in the streamers is they
put you in subcategories Rotten Tomatoes
accredited is a category critically
acclaimed is a category on Netflix for
example this is one more category you're
going to be in when people are scrolling
so they can pick you
right that is why Rotten Tomatoes
matters and that's why this person who
will go unamed of course uh it was
completely wrong do you believe things
happen when they're supposed to happen
100% 100% I
mean fate Karma whatever you want to say
um I
feel there is what you put out of the
universe that you get back a lot of
times and I feel like if you put the
work in and you put your heart into
something sometimes it won't happen for
you but sometimes it does happen for you
and I think that look hard no no one no
one can decry hard work but as long as
you're working smart that's the other
thing too like don't work just don't put
your slay your head against the wall
again and again learn from your mistakes
figure out ways to make things work when
they're not working and try to surround
yourself with people who are like-minded
people who want to get stuff done who
aren't just like the people that are
like oh we're going to sit around and
look at the sky maybe one day we'll do
that no we're we're the getting
done crew okay and I I want to surround
myself with those people and that's
that's going to be our team that's who
we want to work with that's that's what
you need to work with if you want to be
serious about this business do you think
that there's a way to tell who those
people are when you first meet them or
no it takes time I think it takes time I
think it takes time you got to see look
you meet a guy and he's like I'm working
on the script and 10 years later I'm
working on the script okay great well
you keep working on that script that's
cool you know
um it's it's it's sad to say but like I
think there's there's a
certain there's a certain level of
person who's a serious person and
there's a certain level of person who's
like living in LA and working at
Starbucks and call calling themselves an
actor who's not really an actor right
now or not trying to be an actor who's
not like taking the classes in their
spare time or you know what I mean like
acting in short films for free uh
because they just want to they're hungry
and they want to get a good re and and
hopefully get a good Agent or manager
whoever's going to help him go to the
next level um you want to surround
yourself with that serious type of
person you don't want a person who's
like kind of half in half out but that's
not something you could be able to
discern right away I mean you meet
someone in a party you don't know about
them but you know you meet them at a
party again well I'm I'm going for
Network for this thing oh that's great
that's great you're doing that fantastic
you know good for you I should try to
hire him for the thing you know whatever
it is so we can get him cheap well you
know we still we still we still get them
for
cheap do we always wish we'd find our
way
sooner I mean that's 100% I think
everyone looks back on what they could
have done or whatever if I you know
actually gone to USC and gone to film
school instead of going to being a
psychoo major although I'll tell you
this you know doing that helped me out
quite a lot in terms of like testing
movies like you know there's a
psychology that goes into an audience
there's also a psychology that goes into
filmmakers How can I calm this person
down he's a crazy person he's literally
a crazy person I need to like figure out
how to like you know crazy talk that
person down or whatever I got to be like
the crazy Whisperer or something like
that so psychology definitely help with
that um you know look I
mean would I have traded 18 years of
doing market research for being a
producer sooner in some ways no because
I think it gave me a different
perspective a different perspective that
a lot of filmmakers don't have and I I
think I see
things more sometimes and fault me or
not from a Commerce aspect than an art
aspect I see both but I don't think that
people who are artists necessarily see
the Commerce and they need to see the
Commerce unfortunately like they they
they are unaware that this thing is
going to need to be sold it's going to
need to be like packaged it's going to
need to be a lot of different things
before people actually ever watch it and
then you get a claim and quote unquote
money and the swimming pool and the
supermodel girl or whatever the hell it
is you want like people want all kinds
of things um you're going to have to
figure out there's there's not just your
vision there is a Commerce of whole
thing and I think that because of what I
did I realized that um and I it's part
of my DNA so I think that um I bring
that to the table that I wouldn't have
before if I hadn't done the job I did
before